I think some of us are like a little
afraid of merging with God because your
specialness goes like if you become one
with everything that means there's no
two that means there's no special yes
and it's its own type of annihilation
and I think a big part of our job here
on Earth is to recognize that that's
actually not to be feared it's this
weird
play we're putting on for each other of
Separation but like the Oneness isn't to
be you shouldn't be afraid of it yes in
theory I just remember reading some
things all things as a kid where uh not
a kid but in college where they'd be
like you know do you remember before you
were alive it's just that and I was like
that's horrifying I take no comfort in
this at all I don't want to go to before
I was alive I just had a very like
gripping like anxiety in college that I
was like trying to solve and that's how
I became skeptical because I think I
like went down all the Avenues and
looked into all the things and for a
second believed the the the psychic
thing and then read read the amazing
Randy thing and I was like [__] it's
[__] it's [__] [__] turn the
pages with his breath
yeah the random number generator the the
the Stanford experiment of ESP what was
that it's just like I know the random
number generator sure it's uh I think it
was at Stanford I forget what it was
called but they had like a department of
psychic studies and this is how the CAA
would you know The Men Who Stare at
Goats that movie it's it's that CIA CIA
but yeah I am not uh but just these big
groups of organizations who actually
took this seriously in the ways that it
was people being Bamboozled people
people wait so the random number
generator I thought it was like whenever
there were like like 911 or a huge
earthquake or a tsami the numbers tended
to be like these similar numbers what
what is the one here was the idea that a
random number generator should be random
but if you get some psychic in another
room going two two two you're gonna have
more twos than statistically average
over there and then there's a billion
ways to misinterpret the data and I
understand and there's a confirmation
bias of course yeah and I think it's
overwhelming to see how many adults like
who are like anti-religion but they
bought some of the [__] you know uh uh
Elizabeth kuberos uh she's the seven
stages of grief okay she you know
brilliant psychologist that that thing
is a known she got really into a psychic
who uh would bring back dead husbands
and sleep with them and and then that's
what happened what it was him
it was him what wrapping himself in
cheesecloth which is is the reason is
cheesecloth is because it's easy to
stuff in crevices like a shitload of
cheese gloss in your mouth or your
[__] I guess wait hold on is this a
bit no tell then back it up just a
little bit psychic Camp psychic camp
where where this primarily widows would
come yes and they would they would do a
ceremony where he'd bring back their
husbands okay so they could have a final
uh [__] them with cheesecloth so what he
would do what these psychics would do is
basically they're doing magic right so
the way that they would do this magic
trick of the spirit reappearing is they
would have translucent cheesecloth and
the reason it's cheesecloth is because
you can get a lot really small put it
somewhere in your body you can hide it
it's a magic trick and so you turn off
the lights
and then he who comes out he comes out
and they they think it's their husband
okay hold on so the illusion the
attempted illusion is a physical yes
translucent looking person comes into
the room and because of confirmation
guys you wanted to be so true you
covered in cheesecloth looks enough like
my dead husband in the dark room and
you're cheesed yeah and I go there he
has a dick that's a hit but she would
put the cheesecloth on herself no no he
he would he's pretending he's a bee he's
either the psychic he's saying this
woman was in this camp and defended this
guy I see and and basically he got away
with it for a long time but then I I
think crabs spread around the camp and
they said what are these ghost crabs
where are they coming from like like uh
like a pubic hair and he was [__]
them he was [__] them and in the
cheesecloth in the cheesecloth so he put
it on I'm your husband let's let's [__]
that would know I was it wasn't me
because every time we have sex I go what
a baby Reno
in the past 10 years without me going
what a baby Reno that's if if this
[__] didn't know to say what a
baby I shouldn't be sharing the end is
this is this is that when it's coming no
what a baby Arena no it's not like that
it's the corniest because I feel so safe
and she and her clothes come off and it
just comes out and involuntarily I just
go what a baby Reno but your dad would
love it it's Italian sounding mid in the
middle at the end no it's at the
beginning oh it's like you're smooching
that's what I mean the clothes come off
and it Bears a comment so I say what a
baby Arena sure and then now it's kind
of become a thing I didn't mean to take
away from the cheesecloth store no I
think maybe that's how the camp it'll be
a better way for the camp to go down my
wife's like baby what are you doing you
haven't said it say it say it there's a
million okay I know my baby Reno thing
is just kind of a bit but there's a
million
there's no one that could have sex with
Valerie in the way that we have sex she
knows you know what I mean yes people's
sex styles are like thumb prints sure so
there's just a psychic covered in
cheesecloth like like like this is a
non-jokey version but if he licked her
ear I'm not an ear licker like if sure
there's a million Amazing Quiz maybe
before in the readings he goes like your
husband says oh he loved it when you did
the thing what was the thing again like
maybe that's pretty he's finding out
he's finding out and and you used to
love it when he would always say what
did he say and then he's like I'm not
gonna say that this is like he goes I'm
not gonna say that you can bust me I'm
not gonna say babe Reno
that's when he he turns himself in he
goes this is not right what I'm doing
you know what this is not right would
you agree do you have a partner I do and
if you if we're dead and she saw
cheesecloth there's got to be a jean
Marco sure like hey I have an early
morning
hilarious also just like the way you
kiss or don't kiss of course yes that's
a sad you're sad you'll believe it and
this woman this psychologist I mean it
tastes like cheese Club it's exactly
yeah but he's crabs that's how bad that
and I well the crabs Val would be like
this is him I'm just kidding
oh yeah
[Music]